welcome back let's talk money and how
you can start protecting your finances
and the age of covet 19. kendall tenney
sits down with an expert for more here's
their conversation
jerry you have a workshop or seminar
coming up
this week that's going to help people
who maybe are not currently investing in
the market or
worried about investing during this
uncertain time right
exactly um we're having an investor
forum and it's wednesday august 26
from 4 30 to 5 30 and it's free of
charge so we welcome all nevadans to
come join us
but basically because of the coronavirus
pandemic we know
that investors have questions about
how to handle the market volatility that
we've been seeing
we've seen record highs and and record
lows for that matter
since march and um so how do you
protect your finances where can you get
information
we have a special guest actually two
special guests senator
catherine cortez masto will be joining
us and also the nevada securities
commissioner aaron houston
so our whole goal is to provide
information and resources
on where you can turn to find a
registered financial professional and to
get good investment advice
is it a good time for people to be
looking at
investing in the market you know it's
always a good time
to be thinking about where investing
fits in
with your financial goals everybody's
financial goals
are different regardless of how much
money you have
um there's often a good path to
investing regardless of what the markets
are doing
some of the tips that people will hear
is how you can focus
on the long term rather than the short
term and to
avoid things like market timing because
you know
there's always market cycles they're not
always
quite as extreme as we saw in march and
april
but markets go up and markets go down so
the
time now is to think about how to be a
smarter investor
so people can sign up for this how well
just go to our website it's very easy
finra dot org slash
nevada forum that's finra f as in frank
i n is in nancy r a dot org
slash nevada forum and tell us what
finra is what it stands for and what
it's all about
finra is the financial industry
regulatory authority
and we're a not-for-profit regulator of
one slice of the securities industry
the people who sell stocks bonds mutual
funds and other investments the brokers
so we do that we are empowered by
congress to do what we do
but we are not actually part of the
federal government
jerry walsh thanks so much for your time
today look forward to the upcoming
seminar
thanks for having me finra's free online
investor forum is happening tomorrow
from 4 30 to 5 30 pm
at finra.org forward slash nevada forum
for more information give them a call
202-270-38-71
there's an